ça fait carrière dans le domaine
bancaire et depuis quelques mois elle
est caissière chez IGA
on
socialise avec le monde avec on
travaille ça fait 15 et 55 il travaille
20 heures semaine plus pour le plaisir
que pour payer les factures
c'est sur certains c'est plus pour du
luxe
ou des choses que tu es pas obligé de
d'aller dans le vieux gang et comme on
dit bonjour et à 68 ans elle ne se fixe
aucun échéancier pour une retraite
complète moi j'ai toujours dit
faut avoir du plaisir la journée j'avais
plus de plaisir bon restez chez nous le
Québec comptait en 2021 un peu plus de
170 000 travailleurs de 65 ans et plus
c'est vraiment la corde de baby-boomers
qui est l'accord la plus populaire qu'on
n'est jamais connu au Québec qui arrive
à sa tâche de 65 ans et en plus une plus
grande proportion d'entre eux reste au
travail plus longtemps le taux d'emploi
des 65 à 69 ans a Bondy entre 2005 et
2021 de 16 à 25% chez les hommes et de 9
à 16% chez les femmes il y a un facteur
sûrement qui joue c'est celui de la
scolarisation en étant plus scolarisé
ont accès à des emplois de meilleure
qualité moins exigeants physiquement
donc sont quand même de pouvoir y rester
en plus 4 années sur cinq qui ne vivent
pas en établissement se perçoivent comme
étant en bonne santé ceux qui
travaillent le font en moyenne 30 heures
par semaine et on les retrouve dans
toutes les industries dont les services
professionnels la santé et la
fabrication de même que le commerce de
détails et la
restaurations
par exemple en 15 ans la retraite a été
repoussée de 4 ans pour les hommes à 65
ans et de 3 ans pour les femmes à 62 ans
ça fait plaisir aux différentes mesures
gouvernementales qui encouragent la
prolongation carrière par contre il y en
a qui retournent travailler ou qui reste
sur le marché du travail justement parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de fondation les
immigrants aussi sont plus susceptibles
de travailler au-delà de 65 ans ce qui
est normal puisqu'ils arrivent plus tard
au pays donc commencent leur carrière
plus tard souvent à acheter une maison
plus tard etc donc ça retarde beaucoup
de décisions de vie notamment celle de
la retraite
pour d'autres c'est la passion qui les
garde au travail le mot retraité et
prescrit de mon vocabulaire Alexandre
Dumas Alexandre Dumas Alexandre Dumas
Radio-Canada Alex prendre du mal a été
journaliste 42 ans dont 33 Radio-Canada
j'adore que des choses bougent je suis
constamment mouvement comme on dit avec
l'image populaire de hamster roulent
toujours
par exemple ça arrive que je me disais
à bientôt 74 ans il travaille encore à
temps plein
j'ai la prétention de doser penser que
tant que la santé me permettra moi je
regarde en avant jamais dans le
rétroviseur visière levé au cours des
prochaines années le pourcentage des 65
ans est plus qui travaillent devraient
continuer d'augmenter quoi que moins
fortement par contre leur nombre lui
diminuera à partir de 2030 puisque les
générations qui suivent les bébés
boomers sont beaucoup plus petites mais
c'est Marie-Claude Morin Radio-Canada
Montréal